let's get back into the voicemails time
to listen to what the fans are thinking
hit me hi Conan Sona and Matt this is
Brian Perman from New York I'm sitting
here minding my own business doing some
work and listening to your podcast
actually when I get a text from my wife
who tells me that she just walked by
Conan O'Brien on the streets of New York
City on the upper west side she smiled
at you and you said hey first of all
amazing coincidence but second of all do
I need to be worried please let me know
oh a worried I remember this encounter
very well and yes Brian you do need to
be late you definitely because I had an
immediate connection really with this
woman yeah nice and uh things are moving
quickly what about your wife what about
my wife hey you know what about hey I'm
not dead is that what you say when
you're like spitting game you're like
hey I'll go like hey yeah really um yeah
a lot of times I tap women on the
shoulder and they turn around and I go
hey that doesn't go over well yeah yeah
and sometimes I'm wearing a Halloween
mask none of it goes of your face no
it's mixed it's always Nixon
um
I'm Nixon
um no I don't I do I'm I think I'm a
genial well you've been with me a lot
I'm very genial to people on the street
and if someone recognizes me and smiles
or something I'll go hi you know hey
you're very you're really right I hope
that this woman in question didn't feel
in any way that I was stepping over the
line I don't think I was you would have
mentioned that maybe she was
reciprocating and is kind of thinking of
you and dreaming of you you know well I
don't think so why just going off of
past experience
come on no I would say uh I like uh
chatting with people and I like talking
to people and so I'm the complete
opposite
of someone who might be recognizable who
would
um feel like there's time and space was
being invaded I'm the exact opposite of
that person and you walk everywhere when
you're in New York so you're and you're
I don't know you're very recognizable
and into New York it's like you you
really I feel like a walk that would
take anybody else five minutes takes you
like an hour why because you're saying
hi to everyone and you're taking
pictures anybody who asks anybody who
has to take a picture with you you will
take a picture so if you see Conan ask
him to take a picture oh I had someone
asked me recently they said uh they had
just met me and we were trying for a
second they said uh how come you're so
like kind of you know you seem kind of
humble and down to earth and I said a
lot of self-hate and the person that's
what I said I said oh I think a lot of
self-hate and the person went I get that
oh no no I'm kind of kidding kind of
kidding but I but anyway
um that's nice I I uh I I was walking in
New York City with Mr Adams uh Adam
sacks remember and we were walking
together and you saw
a post on like dumois seconds afterwards
you want to lean in and tell this we
were walking together we were in New
York City doing some had some meeting or
something and then we're walking up uh
right past Rockefeller Center yeah and
then uh someone said someone texted me a
like an Instagram post from dumwa that
was like uh a picture of me and you
together and it was like Conan and his
intern walking through
internet yeah yeah Adam Conan with his
13 year old nephew exactly get us some
Cokes sure yeah whatever you want that
is a funny thing now is is people can
kind of just keep tabs on you because
there are all these websites that say
yeah you know I just saw whatever Conan
or whoever eating a Cobb salad it
doesn't even have to be interesting it's
just eating a Cobb salad and uh you
think okay this is gonna make it very
difficult for me
to murder because there's going to be a
trail do you already have a victim in
mind yes I do is it in this room this
victim can't say uh cannot say okay but
anyway
sleep tight
very well fix that second floor window
in the kitchen oh my God first we gotta
Get a Second Story
damn it I had the wrong house I've been
menacing the wrong people well oh Brian
um I uh you do not need to worry and I
think I am no threat okay so uh my best
to you and your does anyone say did he
mention her name no no well I'll just
have to say lady yeah your lady
uh you just lost her
she's gone yeah
um well I hope we cleared that up we did
good job everybody good job and uh Brian
my best to you and your lady